[Applause]
the collapse of Venezuela's economy both
horrifying and predictable and the world
needs to understand why Venezuela has
the world's largest proven oil reserves
and it was once Latin America's richest
country no records those swinging city
of Venezuela
good Drive it's fine buildings right
highways raise 20 on them all in all a
pretty nice place to be for many reasons
today most grocery store shelves are
empty and Venezuelans are so hungry that
they're killing zoo animals for
sustenance toilet paper diapers and
toothpaste our luxury goods then as well
and hospitals have disintegrated
children are dying because they can't
get antibiotics and the infant mortality
rate is higher than Syria's the capital
city of Caracas is the murder capital of
the world and just 12 percent of
citizens feel safe walking alone at
night which is the lowest figure
reported in the world the government
blames slumping oil prices for the
desperate situation but the real cause
is the socialist economy the government
sets the price of staples such as rice
pasta and flour resulting in chronic
shortages former President Hugo Chavez
nationalized industries confiscated
property kicked out foreign companies
the government is trying to print its
way out of the crisis resulting in a 700
percent annual inflation rate after a
sham election President Nicolas Maduro
the hand-picked successor of Chavez is
rounding up his opponents and putting
them in jail
despite this Maduro and his predecessor
still have their defenders ranging from
Sean Penn to Michael Moore to Naomi
Klein who once signed a petition saying
we would vote for Hugo Chavez and
praised the autocrat in 2007 for
creating a zone of relative economic
calm and predictability in 2013
journalist David Sirota praised Hugo
Chavez an economic miracle writing that
the socialist leader had a record that a
legacy obsessed American president could
only dream of achieving but the real
lesson of Venezuela's tragic collapse is
that real socialism always leads to
economic breakdown and political
repression those of us in wealthier
freer countries need to keep them as
well in mind as
we confront calls for more regulation
and government control of all aspects of
our lives
[Music]